Friendships can hold an exceptional
place in our life stories.
What is it about these connections
that make them so unique?
Before we dive into the science,
let’s first observe one in action.
If I could somehow design
a best friend, you know,
put together all the ideal qualities
of my perfect match,
that person would pale
in comparison to Priya.
She can turn any situation
into a good time—
chemistry lab, band practice.
What I’m trying to say is I never laugh
harder than when I’m with Priya.
And she’s always there for me.
Like last year after I got dumped by Te—
you know what?
I don’t even want to mention their name.
It felt like my whole world
was crashing down.
But as soon as I told Priya, boom,
she was at my door.
I was a wreck,
but she sat there with me and listened.
We’re always on the same page;
it’s as if we can read each other’s minds!
And we can talk for hours— about anything.
I know my mom would say she has
the phone bills to prove it.
If it seems like friendships formed
in adolescence are particularly special,
that’s because they are.
Early childhood, adolescent,
and adult friendships
all manifest a little differently
in part because the brain works
in different ways at those stages of life.
Adolescence is a unique time when
peer relationships take focus,
and thanks to the developing brain,
there are changes in the way you value,
understand, and connect to friends.
Teenage friends can seem
attached at the hip.
Scientists describe adolescence
as a social reorientation
as teenagers begin to spend
as much or more time
with their friends
than with their parents.
This drive to hang with pals may be due
to changes in the brain’s reward center,
known as the ventral striatum.
Its activation makes hanging
out with others enjoyable
and motivates you to spend
more time with them.
Neuroimaging studies show that this region
is highly reactive
during your teenage years,
which may explain why adolescents
seem to place a higher value
on social interactions
than children or adults.
Teenage friendships can also
feel more intimate
than the friendships of your childhood.
This deeper connection is possible thanks
to improvements
in what scientists call Theory of Mind.
Theory of Mind is the ability
to understand others’ emotions,
thoughts, motivations, and points of view,
and to realize that they may
be different from your own.
While it may seem intuitive,
this ability hinges on the careful
coordination of various brain regions,
sometimes referred to as the social brain.
Babies begin to develop Theory of Mind
around 18 months or so.
Before that, it’s thought they believe
that everyone perceives and knows
exactly what they know.
It was once considered to be
fully developed by age five,
but scientists now know
that Theory of Mind
continues to improve and mature
well into your teenage years and beyond.
Likewise, regions within the social brain
show increased connectivity
during adolescence compared
with childhood.
As a result, teens can better understand
their friend’s perspectives,
allowing for deeper connections
to flourish.
In the closest friendships,
it can almost feel as if you’re
metaphysically connected—
two bodies and minds, perfectly in sync.
And there is science to this!
Your ability to connect with others
somewhat depends
on the coordination of actions, emotions,
physiology, and thoughts.
This is what psychologists call
interpersonal synchrony.
You first show signs of the ability
to sync with others as infants—
synchronizing movements
and babbling with your parents.
As you get older and spend more time
outside the home,
you increasingly show this synchrony
with your peers.
For example, imagine walking
down the street with a friend.
Often without consciously thinking,
you stroll at the same pace
and follow the same path.
You and your best friend may
not be only on the same page,
but also scientifically, in step.